um simulation of Hamiltonians they
always think you know oh this is for
chemistry you know this is all that's
all that these applications are set up
for the right way to think about
Hamiltonian simulation is Hamiltonian
simulation is a compilation paradigm it
says for cases where you want to
implement a unitary matrix but you only
know that unitary matrix as an
exponential of a hermitian matrix this
tells you how to compile that into a
sequence of gates and so these
techniques of course have found
applications all over the place because
of the fact that it's kind of one of the
broadest set of techniques that we end
up having for naturally of course
because there's been so much attention
because of the applications to chemistry
or field theory there have been a host
of advant advantage in the last little
while and I'm going to be talking about
a number of papers here I was on the
majority of them but I'll partially be
talking about this one over here that
I'm not on which is a kind of a simpler
version of the paper that go on how and
I did so the basic basic thing that I
want to be able to get across is I
really want to get across how some of
the techniques that have shown up in
these papers have really actually kind
of caused us to have a better unified
understanding of how many of these
methods play together and exactly what
the actual errors are and one of the
most surprising results that actually
ends up coming out of this is that we
find you know methods from linear
combinations of unitary over here that
actually can in some cases dramatically
outperform quote-unquote you know
optimal simulation methods by exploiting
structure in the matrix but the thing
that's really kind of neat is that these
techniques ended up showing us that we
can actually simulate some problems in
chemistry much more efficiently than we
figured but recent Rewa work that was
done but with Johann sue Andrew and a
bunch of other people ended up actually
showing that even just using a dumb
trotter formula believe it or not for
these problems without using any of
those fancy techniques we can come close
to matching the same performance and so
these are this
ends up showing that actually yeah
there's more life in Trotter than
probably I would have guessed two years
previous so to talk about it yeah
basically that yeah this is what I'm
going to going to do I'm going to talk
about basically mostly mostly what I'm
going to talk about is time-dependent
simulation the reason why is almost all
of the techniques that I'm going to be
talking about even when we're taking a
look at time independent Hamiltonian
are going to actually end up using time
dependent Hamiltonian as part of the
proof technique so I'm going to need to
spend some time reminding you about how
simulation for time dependent
Hamiltonian ends up looking then I'm
going to talk about improved bounds for
the Trotter formula and show how these
improve bounds actually can end up with
the yielding simulations of field theory
well at least a very simple lattice
gauge Theory where the Trotter
simulation actually outperforms what we
would end up seeing if we used an
optimal method like qubit ization or
linear combinations of unit ares so
that's sort of the overview of the talk
and so okay time-dependent Hamiltonian
what are they and why do we need them
well time-dependent Hamiltonian
basically model systems that have
external classical control so imagine
what you have is you have say a pair of
molecules that are colliding together
if those molecules are sufficiently
heavy basically the center of mass for
the nuclei as they're going towards each
other
can be treated classically or semi
classically whereas the electrons
because they're so much lighter
often you'll need a full quantum
mechanical treatment from that
perspective the position of the the
nuclei I can be seen it's just a
time-dependent classical trajectory that
these things are going through in which
case the nuclear force is acting on the
electrons are going to also be time
dependent so that's an example of a time
fittin Hamiltonian but perhaps the one
that everybody here is most familiar
with is a quantum computer itself
because with the quantum computer right
what you want to do is you want to be
able to turn on and off gates at
different times based on classical
control signals and so from that
perspective the mathematical model of
that quantum system is fundamentally
given by time-dependent Hamiltonian
and the thought about quantum simulation
methods for time-dependent Hamiltonian
actually began by studying models like
adiabatic quantum computing in order to
be able to show that adiabatic quantum
computing is equivalent to ordinary
quantum computing it was necessary to
show that the time-dependent Hamiltonian
as it uses can be simulated on a quantum
computer so that's actually where all of
this this stuff originally ended up
getting developed so alright cool so
before if you've got a time-dependent
Hamiltonian then the time evolution
operator is the solution to this
operator differential equation up here
so normally if we'd have this the
solution would be like a matrix
exponential to this e to the minus IHT
but the problem is is that if H is a
function of time it turns out that there
isn't a closed form expression in
general for this and the symbolic
solution that we use for the solution is
this time ordered operator exponential
over here ok and if we want to get a
better idea about what this thing looks
like the easiest way to do this is to do
a look at the Dyson series for it which
is and the easiest way to find out what
the Dyson series is is to do a Wikipedia
search but because of the fact that I
don't do Wikipedia search what I did
last night to make sure I got the
formula right is I did a Bing search and
this apparently is what the Dyson series
is ok it's less funny but it turns out
the next link that it recommends
actually is the Dyson series of
Wikipedia or alternatively you can go on
Google and the number one link is
actually what you want but anyway it's
the real Dyson series is actually this
thing over here so the this over here
you can think of as a generalization of
a Taylor series in fact actually for the
case where all of the the Hamiltonian
terms are time independent when you do
all these integrals you end up getting
the 1 over n factorial terms that you
would end up expecting so really is just
a generalization of Taylor's there but
there's what a couple of things that
it's important to note
are a little bit subtle and different
about this the first thing is is that H
of T right it's a time-dependent matrix
so it may not actually commute with
itself at all times so that means that
when we're considering simulating a
Dyson series the ordering of when each
of these Hamiltonian terms ends up
occurring inside this sum is really
important and that that's going that's
something that's going to be important
to bear in mind when we talk about
simulating this on quantum computers
because what we're going to have to do
in order to implement this is we're
going to have to keep track of when each
of those individual Hamiltonian terms is
supposed to fire by creating an auxilary
clock register okay so that's basically
how the whole thing ends up going so a
couple of problems existed you know kind
of two years back in the in the era that
andrush was mostly talking about
although he did cheat in the end and
ended up giving away some of my punch
lines but that aside from that point the
kind of questions that we were asking is
okay if we're looking at simulating a
time-dependent Hamiltonian of this form
does the scaling of the simulation end
up depending on kind of the average case
properties of the Hamiltonian because
obviously if you got a Hamiltonian
that's depending on time right it could
happen that at some point in time the
Hamiltonian becomes ludicrously
difficult to simulate and then after
that it's trivial like it for example if
you had an impulsive interaction right
where the interaction is basically zero
zero zero zero then all of a sudden
there's an incredibly strong interaction
between two systems in that case if you
had to pay the full cost for simulation
when the systems aren't interacting that
would be incredibly wasteful and it was
unknown at the time whether or not it
was possible even to be able to get
simulation methods that scaled with kind
of the average value of the Hamiltonian
rather than the worst-case value the
next question is what what's the role of
the derivatives of the Hamiltonian if
the Hamiltonian is changing over time
right then it may it makes sense that
the smoothness of the Hamiltonian should
somehow be relevant for the simulation
and so question is well how is it
polynomial is it logarithmic how
end up coming in and with all the
analyses that had been done on the
Trotter formula side of things it
strongly suggested that in many cases
the dependence was polynomial however
there was randomized work that ended up
coming out earlier by I think poulin
verse strata and Soma
that ended up showing that actually the
low-order formulas ended up existing
that only depended on the average
formula that worked basically by Monte
Carlo sampling terms in the Hamiltonian
and using a Monte Carlo integral in
order to effectively approximate this up
here so that was the intuition behind it
their method so those are sort of the
main questions and the first kind of
stab at this that I'm going to be
talking about is the linear combinations
approach now something that's actually
kind of interesting is that Q drift
which was Earl Campbell's approach you
know sometimes you would she called a
randomized compiler for evolution
actually the interesting thing is is
that it actually really should be
thought of not like a Trotter formula
kind of like earl campbell suggested it
was but rather it should actually be
thought of as a linear combination of
unitary method okay so the basic idea is
and rush ended up saying in his talk is
that if we've got a Hamiltonian
that's a sum of a bunch of unitary
operations then what we can do is we can
create a circuit that block encodes the
Hamiltonian by using these two objects
that prepare and a select register over
here and basically what the prepare
register ends up doing is it ends up
preparing the coefficients of the state
and the select ends up implementing each
of the individual terms of this linear
combination and selected on measuring 0
up here at the end you'll have applied
the Hamiltonian to it and you can use
this idea in order to be able to
implement a Taylor series because the
Taylor series is just a sum of
Hamiltonian and using this trick to do a
sum of sums then you can end up
implementing e to the minus IHT
so what we're going to do in this
particular case is if we want to be able
to apply this to a time dependent
Hamiltonian well we'll do the exact same
thing but to a Dyson series all right
now let's take a look
huge rift though in this framework the
cue drift algorithm actually is really
really simple what it actually ends up
looking like is this okay so the main
difference between the two is in for LC
you what you have is you have a whole
bunch of unit Ares that are all being
quantumly controlled and fired
you know fired coherently with these
prepare circuits telling you with what
amplitude you should be be firing them
with Q drift
you don't do that at all what you do is
you decompose the evolution into a bunch
of unit ares and then you monte carlo
sample over those unitary so you replace
the quantum control with classical
control now the scaling of the
algorithms it turns out is actually very
similar the scaling ends up depending on
for LCU on the sum of the absolute
values of these coefficients and
similarly for Q drift it also depends
with some of the absolute values of the
coefficients it does not depend on the
commutator like it trotter formulas do
so that's the idea and one of the the
cute things about Q drift is the fact
that unlike LCU it doesn't require all
of these additional qubits and if you're
looking at applying something on
near-term quantum quantum devices where
you've got a small number of qubits LC
you can be kind of punishing because of
that whereas Q drift isn't now it could
this will come at a price but the
question is if we're looking at
simulating time-dependent Hamiltonian
switch is the most general case that we
can kind of look at at least for
hamiltonian simulation what kind of
overheads end up coming in with that and
so that's the first thing I'm going to
begin with because from my perspective
LCU is actually a little more
complicated in Q drift because with Q
drift well we don't have the control
register so basically the idea ends up
being same with what we want to do is we
want to be able to approximate the time
time order to operate our exponential
which in is this thing over here so the
way that we end up doing this is that
what what we do is we can say that all
right let's take this channel over here
so what this channel ends up doing is it
says okay I'm going to assume that my
Hamiltonian only contains one term
just for simplicity here okay but that
term is time-dependent so in order to be
able to simulate it what I do is I pick
a time randomly between the beginning
and end point with some weight and then
only evolve the system for a short time
step according to that fixed Hamiltonian
that I sample all right now if you if
you go through the Taylor series
expansion of this channel over here
versus the Dyson series up here then
what you end up getting is you end up
finding that this over here it's a
leading order will end up actually
causing the peas over here to cancel so
any probability distribution that you
end up picking will end up actually
giving you the leading order the time
evolution that you need so that's
actually really kind of neat and the but
the question is how do you end up
choosing this probability the idea
basically is that just like important
sampling you want to be able to pick the
probability distribution that kind of
minimizes the variance in some sense of
all of these terms because what will end
up happening is that if we choose a very
bad P of P of tau over here for this
distribution then the higher order terms
are just going to kind of go all over
the place so the natural choice to end
up to do is to basically end up picking
each of the terms according to the
maximum value of the earth through the
the Staten infinity norm which is like
the spectral norm of the Hamiltonian
evaluated at a particular time divided
by a normalized normalizing coefficient
which is really just the integral of all
of those so this is the probability
distribution that we pick that will
minimize these errors on top of that and
then what we can do is we can say that
if we end up picking it according to
this then the diamond distance between
the channel that we would like to do for
the ideal time evolution operator and
the one that we get by randomly sampling
a time evolution at one of those points
and
actually just going like the square of
the spectral norm integrated over time
so what this ends up saying is something
really kind of cool right the air in
this case doesn't actually end up
depending on the maximum value of the
function in between because we're
randomly sampling this argument ends up
saying that actually depends on the
average value so if you've got a case
that ends up looking like a you know
kind of like a Dirac Delta function
that's strongly impulsive this
discussion this uh this lemma ends up
saying that that doesn't matter the
thing that matters is the integral so if
the average of the impulse over the
entire interval is decent then the cost
of simulation isn't actually all that
high which is a which is kind of a cool
result and by the way I should mention
that this result over here technically
is only really you will end up giving
you a good bound for a short time
evolution because this subscript one it
means the integral over the time that
you're looking at so if we want to break
this up into a sequence of along the
evolution time this will kind of go
quadratically with the evolution time so
we what we want to do is we want to
break this up into a series of short
evolutions and slice them together when
we slice them together what we end up
finding more or less is that the total
complex 'ti of the simulation ends up
going like the sum of the absolute
values of the the individual
coefficients in the Hamiltonian
integrated over time squared okay so it
scales like the average value of the
coefficients even when we slice this up
into a series of short times time steps
and again this is fantastic because of
the fact that if we had have used say Oh
older school trotter formulas we would
have ended up getting scaling that
depended on you know the maximum value
or the average value but it would also
have had parameters that depend on the
higher-order derivatives this formula
does not actually depend whatsoever on
the derivatives it only depends on the
average value so that's that's really
kind of cool
and so the question is alright great
this is what we ended up getting by
doing things using classical control if
we go back and you know consider the LCU
to cue drift mapping and replace the
classical control of all the unit Ares
that we end up having in here with
quantum control then what exactly are
the advantages that we could conceivably
get for this and so going through the
way that we end up doing is as I
mentioned before is we use a truncated
Dyson series expansion so we use that
Dyson series but with fewer vacuums I
guess unless you're simulating field
theory good anyways the the the Dyson
series the one of the key things that
ends up differing from the truncated
Taylor series simulation that and Roush
talked about is that what we need to do
is when we're triggering all of these
individual Hamiltonians we need to we
need to encode the clock lock register
that tells each of those hamiltonian
terms whether it's time for them to fire
or whether it's not time for them to
fire when we're discretizing is integral
because if we discretize this integral
and we have you know t1 over here
happening before t2 then these things
are out of order right because this
these integrals have a very specific
order about when each of them supposed
to go in so what we need to do is we
need to not only set up a clock but we
need to make sure that the times
associated with that clock are properly
ordered and this can be done using some
comparison logic and basically the idea
is is that we set up some amplitudes on
each of the individual times and then we
test to see whether or not the term is
out of order or not and the simplest
version of this ends up basically
setting the amplitude to zero for all
out of order terms by doing a comparison
test
ok then this circuit will we'll end up
checking for it so of the version
version of this that guang how and I
ended up doing when we went through the
entire construction we've did all the
linear combinations
unit Ares use oblivious amplitude
amplification in order to boost the
probability of success to basically a
hundred percent then what we end up
getting is we end up getting a following
result to contextualise it the the most
important thing is that we end up
getting nearly near simulation
near linear scaling with a simulation
time over here we get linear scaling
with the maximum value of the
Hamiltonian in each of the segments now
that's a bit of a bummer
compared to cue drift what we can do is
if we have an idea of how bad though the
the norm the Hamiltonian is in each of
these individual segments we can kind of
we can we can deal with that a little
bit by adjusting the algorithm
appropriately and slicing up the time
evolution but if we're not given any
promises about how bad the norm of the
Hamiltonian is in each of the segments
unfortunately actually this approach is
inferior to the random sampling where
Monte Carlo integration comes through
and saves the day effectively okay so
that's what we end up getting from it
but the thing that actually really kind
of struck me about this which is kind of
you know remarkable is that in terms of
the queries to the to an Oracle that
encodes the Hamiltonian the cost does
not depend on the derivatives of the
Hamiltonian it only depends on the
magnitude of the Hamiltonian so what
that says is that says apart from this
logarithmic cost which comes in from
setting the scale of the or the
discretization of the clock that we're
using the derivatives actually more or
less don't matter for the simulation
method which is kind of you know it's
suppose it is so surprising when I
started with cue drift where they
literally don't matter but in this case
we've got nearly optimal scaling and
worst case scenario have logs scaling
with the derivatives and so I focus on
this yeah
has this motive of one rational I know
actually Scott polynomial dependence
this is much better vastly better in a
in that it's quadratically better in
terms of the scaling with time to so the
question is because of this gulf between
that can you actually exploit the fact
that simulating very rapidly changing
Hamiltonians in some sense is
exponentially better than what you would
believe if you just used naive time
slicing and the answer is yeah you can
and the idea behind this is the
interaction picture simulation method
and the idea is imagine you've got two
terms in your Hamiltonian right a and b
what we can do is we can end up
basically saying alright let's now go
into and we can take some of the time
dependence for one of the terms and
absorb that time dependence in the state
and at the price of making our time to
independent Hamiltonian time dependent
so if we've got a really big term that's
evolving like crazy causing the phase to
kind of wrap around what we can do is we
can absorb the dynamics of that quickly
evolving thing at the price of having a
very very rapidly changing hamiltonian
but i just said that you don't have to
pay a big cost using the previous method
if you've got a rapidly varying
hamiltonian you only pay cost that goes
like the derivative are the the log of
the derivative not linearly with the
derivative so by taking a big term in a
hamiltonian shifting it into the
interaction frame that you're using in
this representation you can use the
truncated a dyson series method to get
huge advantages for simulating the
hamiltonian and so the the key point is
that if you end up doing this here's the
theorem I won't bother boring you with
the details but the key thing is is that
the if you do this and you can fast
forward to the dynamics is then simulate
the dynamics of the expensive term at
low cost or constant or logarithmic for
that matter then in that case what the
cost basically only ends up depending on
the magnitude of the smaller term and
logarithmically
the bigger one and so you know to just
to give you an example if you had a
diagonally dominant Hamiltonian of this
form over here where you've got terms
that are say a million on the diagonal
versus relatively small terms on the
off-diagonal this sort of a
transformation is enormous ly valuable
because otherwise you would have had to
have paid full cost for all of these
terms whereas if you use the interaction
picture you only have to pay logarithmic
cost for those diagonal terms and this
ended up actually kind of inspiring us
because we asked well is chemistry
diagonally dominant and it turns out
yeah actually it is and so we could use
this in order to be able to simulate
chemistry in a plane wave basis and show
that what we can do is we can end up
getting scaling that goes quadratically
with a number of orbitals that we end up
having in the problem whereas the
previous best method ended up going like
a the 8/3 so you know polynomial
speed-up okay not a very big one but it
I still liked it and it still
state-of-the-art scaling but this ends
up bringing up the other point that
andrush ended up raising which is the
unreasonable performance of trotter
formulas so trotter formulas and a scale
far worse at least according to the
bounds that people have looked at in the
past for these problems but the question
is well is this fundamental or is this a
problem with our analysis now to give
you an idea about why there's a problem
with our analysis the standard way that
people ended up taking a look at the air
in trotter formulas let's see if I've
got it nope I don't
standard way that people ended up taking
a look at the air and the Charter
formulas is that you want to be able to
figure out what's the difference between
e to the a plus B and e to the a times e
to the B so a natural tool for looking
at that would be something like the
Baker Campbell house-door formula or the
zazen house formula problem is is that
you get these nasty combinatorial
expansions of exponentially many
commutator x' popping up with it and
being able to go through and bound the
remainder of this series which also
incidentally doesn't converge
in general and it's bounding all of that
stuff and being able to retain the
commutator structure was something that
was actually incredibly difficult and
I'd tried for years and I'd uh turley
failed but thankfully andrew has an
incredibly good graduate student who
realized hey wait a second how about
looking at a this from a different
perspective
can we actually end up looking at the
Trotter formulas themselves as a
time-dependent Hamiltonian so it's a
weird thing but if you think about it
right when you've got a Trotter formula
it's kind of like piecewise constant
it's like one term in a Hamiltonian is
active and the rest are off and then
they're just kind of like switching on
and off like a light switch so at some
level actually fundamentally the object
that you're looking at is actually a
time-dependent Hamiltonian so it becomes
actually more it much more natural to
look at it it use yeah in that language
once you make that realization and so
once that that's used the technique we
use a technique called variation of
parameters to be able to do this and the
key thing is is we get a multiplicative
and also a additive error bound on this
and we end up finding that even for high
order formulas which would have had
exponentially many commutator z' that we
would have had to have bound it using
the standard Baker Kapil house-door
formula like expansion this variation of
parameters trick allows us to explicitly
say yeah actually it ends up depending
on this relatively simple nested norm of
nested commentators up at the top and
this it was a was actually key for us to
be able to analyze what the cost of
chemistry is because in general if we
want to get the best scaling what we
have to do is we have to kind of
iteratively change the order of the
Charter Suzuki approximation as we need
more and more accuracy or the evolution
time stretches out longer and without
these high order bounds like this we had
no idea how the error would actually end
up scaling as we went to bigger and
bigger or higher and higher order
formula
okay and so I'm kind of running low on
time so I'll gloss over all of this the
key result for electronic structure over
here is that we were able to actually
also get order n-squared simulation time
but fortunately you know all of my all
of the work that Guangzhou and I did
ended up doing in for the interaction
picture wasn't totally in vain because
of the fact that there was this little
oh one which caused some consternation
in in and ratchet's talk so the scaling
with time and epsilon is actually worse
its sub polynomial yeah scaling with
epsilon but not poly logarithmic whereas
the truncated Dyson series ends up
getting you poly logarithmic so if you
need extremely accurate scaling with
epsilon the interaction picture of
simulation method is better but if you
only care about your scaling with a
number of orbitals that you have you're
using in your molecular model they're
both basically about the same so what
this ends up showing is that the gulf
between what trotter formulas or at
least high or Detroiter formulas can do
for these applications and what what we
can do using more sophisticated methods
is actually relatively slim also another
thing that i should i should mention
that's really kind of cool is that these
error bounds actually end up being
useful for Monte Carlo simulation
because we can prove multiplicative
forms of this so for Monte Carlo
simulation actually we can look at
simulating transverse sizing models with
a polynomial a better model method
bravi this ended up scaling like n to
the 59 and using our improved air bounds
we can actually bring it down to a
spelled end of the 45 and I'm really
excited about this because this means
that we actually might have a chance now
of applying us algorithm for N equals
two
I know right that's a result only Qi P
could love oh yeah I got accepted there
so I don't have enough time to go over
the technique but it's variation of
parameters and this technique in various
forms actually used for some proofs of
low order charter formulas down by
Hastings at all but here we generalize
it and apply it across the board so I'm
really running out of time but let's
let's now say okay well what if try two
formulas aren't good enough for you
right what if you'd like to have be able
to work in a unified picture between the
two andrush mentioned that there is this
stuff called multi product formulas that
you could potentially do ironically
multi product formulas aren't really a
new LCU technique when Andrew and I
first started looking at this this
approach this was actually the thing
that we we considered but the problem is
is that we didn't know about oblivious
amplitude amplification at the time so
we really couldn't get the success
probability high without using some
crazy gadgets that ended up killing the
performance so Guang Hao and Vadim and I
we started asking well now that we know
about oblivious amplitude amplification
can we get this to work and is there
some way we can use this idea of having
sums of product formulas rather than
sums of ordinary unit Ares to kind of
build a bridge between trotter formulas
and LCU and the answer is yes actually
we can and the way that this ends up
working is actually a very similar idea
to what well address talked about for
constructing high order charter formulas
but because of the fact that the
approximation is a sum of trotter
formulas not a product of them what we
end up with is we end up with actually a
linear system that we have to solve in
order to be able to ensure that the air
cancels to appropriate order so what
this is saying over here is basically we
want the formula to be exact to leading
order but we want all the higher-order
errors to cancel out in a simplest case
this over here yeah can be these
coefficients over here for the terms in
the expansion
can be found by inverting a vandermonde
matrix but we need to do something a
little fancier so what we do is we can
solve this either using linear
programming or an approximate solution
can be found using Chevy chef
polynomials when we stick this in what
we end up getting is we end up getting
basically that we can achieve linear
scaling with with the time in this
particular case and the one norm of the
coefficients in the Hamiltonian and we
can almost get as as good scaling as the
ordinary technique as the optimal
techniques but unfortunately we get log
squared 1 over Epsilon and an open
question is yeah well is it possible
using this technique actor using a
technique to reduce this down the
logarithmic scaling I suspect it's yes
but I don't know how all right now final
thing I'm going to talk about is a
simulation of the Schwinger model so now
that we have these new techniques can we
apply them to some practical example and
get concrete improvements in the gate
counts now thus when your model is
something that people have been talking
about simulating for a while there's a
number of papers on it but a major
problem is is that I found out after
learning about this subject that all
those papers kind of suck and the reason
why they kind of suck is because of the
the the Hamiltonian over here so the
Hamiltonian what it's supposed to model
is electrons and positrons at Nia at
nearby sites that interact with each
other through a gauge field the gauge
field you can sort of think of as being
photons but it's actually not quite so
the basic idea is is that you've got the
electric so there's no Coulomb
interaction just the gauge field ends up
that's kind of simulating that and the
interaction term basically involves a
lowering operator for the electric field
over here in exchange for causing the
electrons to hop or electrons and
positrons top and so that's it looks
kind of like a James Cummings
interaction and so the reason why all of
this kind of sucked in the past was
because of the fact that these raising
and lowering operators all the work
previous to this ended up using a poly
decomposition because they're only
interested in doing us on near-term
devices turns out the poly decomposition
though for the
raising and lowering operators on the
gauge field here you are you are dagger
those actually have an exponentially
large poly decomposition which is sad so
what we had to do is we had to go and
find a new way of doing it turns out the
raising and lowering operators can be
implemented directly but by adding adder
circuits and so by using adders circuits
we were able to come up with a scalable
version of this so we looked at strata
decomposition and the reason why we
looked at the trotter decomposition is
because of the fact that it's got a very
very nice air bound over here see take a
look I mean but the thing that's really
nice about this even though it's ghastly
and there's no chance of you remembering
what it is even if you knew what the
definitions of all of these different
kid hopping as well as diagonal terms in
the Hamiltonian are is that the air as I
said before depends on the commutator
z-- of all of these terms if we go back
and take a look at the commutator z-- it
turns out the lowering operator
commuting with a number operator squared
over here ends up actually lowering the
degree of that that by by one so rather
than the cost because it's a commutator
ending up scaling quadratically with the
maximum electric field that you can end
up having in a problem it turns out
because of the commutator is it only
scales linearly but if we use qubit
ization the LCU or Q drift we'd have to
pay a cost that winds up going like a
maximum value of this ER squared so this
actually ends up leading in the case
where we need a large cut off for our
gauge field to a pretty big advantage
for Trotter over the other techniques so
going through all of this
this one does use a cut off yeah so I
didn't mention the cut off over here but
this cut off value we pick a cut off
value of lambda and so once we end up
hitting it for practical purposes we
assume it's periodic so it just wraps
around but ideally hopefully your field
shouldn't be hitting a cut off anyway so
that choice is kind of irrelevant
well so in terms of like if you when you
set the maximum strength of the field
that you can have at each of these terms
right think of this field as a register
right it's got length two to the N and
so the cost ends up scaling basically
like two to the end effectively and so
the cost that you would end up getting
using qubit ization who is the maximum
value is related to the maximum value of
the gauge field that you can get in each
of those sites whereas with trotter it
depends on the commutator of that
operator and the commutator is
polynomially smaller then the actual
operator in this case and that gives us
an advantage and so when we do this we
end up getting the the following scaling
where we get linear rather than
quadratic scaling with this lambda
parameter which is the cutoff so this
shows that yeah these that a deeper
understanding of trotter formulas can
end up leading to a better understanding
of what the scaling of the resources are
and actually we even went through a
little bit further in this and figured
out the total number of T gays and found
that yeah this looks like a totally
practical application you know for even
modest time evolutions it only takes
like 10 to the 11 gates so you know
anytime now right but the the the
interesting thing is that trotter does
perform very very well for these these
particular cases and we need to continue
to understand how all of these
approximations play together because the
reality is if we want to get these
numbers for these sorts of simulations
down to something lower it's doubtful
that this has got clearly going to be
the method that we pick so by
understanding how all of the different
approximations end up playing together
and perhaps even using them selectively
to dissect different parts of the
problem that's probably what we're going
to actually need in order to be able to
reduce some of these gate gate counts
from depending if we use sampling or
amplitude estimation for this example
down from you know ten to the eight or
ten to the eleventh down to hopefully
something more like ten to the six so
that's basically yet so I think that
actually kind of the biggest message
that I I would like to make about about
how
simulation if you got nothing else out
of the talk really I would say that the
last two years for Hamiltonian
simulation have Madani mental monumental
changes
well Hamill and Hamiltonian well
Hamiltonian simulation itself has
actually been one of the most rapidly
changing parts of quantum algorithms in
general it's actually been accelerating
if anything in terms of both the level
of sophistication for the specialized
algorithms which I didn't talk about or
also the more general algorithms for
simulating arbitrary dynamics there's a
lot of new capabilities that are coming
to play with us and because of the
importance of Hamiltonian simulation is
a fundamental primitive for many other
quantum algorithms I think it's really
important that that people start paying
attention to some of these techniques
because ideas like block encoding as
well as singular value transformation
and some of the related qubit ization
ideas that ended up popping out are
really really important techniques just
to use in general whether you're
interested in linear algebra quantum
machine learning or whatever so I really
think that there's been a huge amount of
change and I'm I'm really excited about
the direction the fields going to go
because I strongly suspect that than
that if somebody's talking about this at
Simons in two years that the next two
years are probably going to have as much
change if not more than a change that
we've seen since the last one thank you
very much
yeah um you made a comment about having
like Delta functions in your time
revolution so for instance if you have a
Hamiltonian and the energy has like over
ends Universal finite wit what type of
Hamiltonian simulation algorithm would
you use this is like where the Trotter
step was actually less than the width of
your lawrencium
but to be able to resolve those dynamics
that are happening on such a fast time
scale so I mean you've got a number of
different options right if you end up
having a priori knowledge about what the
form of the distribution is beforehand
then you can use a whole bunch of
adaptive techniques in order to be able
to deal with that okay assuming you
don't then probably your best bet is
queue drift yeah well either that or
else you can also end up using the pool
on or soma Al Gore a randomized
algorithm one of those two approaches
would probably be the best for you if
you and if you want to do it on
near-term ish devices queue drift
without a question short break before
the panel discussion I think so it's
great to open anything and you know I
was gonna say that when one does
classical simulations with shorter you
know we've always not worried about the
scary bounce at you and I'm glad I wish
the truth this one doesn't have to worry
about it but but what I think um once
they have question I was curious about
this you know the love emphasis on what
I might call the time step error in
trottin how it matters but when when
doing simulations doing numerical
integration that I'm Deborah it's not
necessary the most important thing that
one worries about so when one's
integrating differential equations for
it in time when you have stiff equations
then you can use integrators which you
know accurate to certain orders in time
but some of them if you just if you just
follow them in time design the error
will flow up and then other state went
to great is they you know the the errors
even if the lower order integrators
retain the stables
solution in time and so you know that
would seem to be related to the
robustness of this these types of things
to noise in the quantum setting and
wondering if this is something people
fool about
so some extent it ends up inheriting
some of the the same kind of robustness
because fundamentally the integrators
that we can carry out because we're
limited to applying unitary
transformations they're all symplectic
or approximately symplectic and so
because they're they have that property
there really isn't any anymore than
linear blow up in the air due to due to
finite gates so we don't run into that
problem but the problem is of course
because we're dealing with unitary
dynamics it sometimes becomes very hard
to conceive of how we would block and
code a more sophisticated integrator
that isn't necessarily symplectic is not
sufficient for it to be to always
perform well in stiff equations you can
still have blowup I mean it's cool
integration of empty I mean you can use
simplex it integrates and some of them
will have this but I guess what I'm what
I'm getting at is specifically for
integration of the Schrodinger equation
where from the the unit from the
unitarity you can end up arguing worst
case scenario there's going to be if you
got machine epsilon and n gates you're
going to be you know or epsilon and at
most away from your solution so there
isn't there can't be a blow-up in the
context of the Schrodinger equation but
obviously other dynamical systems yeah
let's like